she is the poor little rich girl who
overcame huge obstacles to become first
lady of the world at the age of nine she
took control of her own destiny
transforming herself from a shy fearful
girl into a strong socially aware and
confident woman as the First Lady of the
United States she took a ceremonial
title and turns it into a platform to
help others and then went even further
and developed the Magna Carta of the
modern age the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights in today's by graphics we
examine the very busy life of Eleanor
Roosevelt Anna Eleanor Roosevelt was
born into one of the richest families in
America the New York Roosevelt's on
October the 11th 1884 her parents Elliot
and Anna were prominent New York
socialites Anna was a strikingly
beautiful woman who loved finery and
perfection Eleanor could tell from an
early age that she was a disappointment
to her mother though she was not pretty
enough and she was too shy and awkward
in Eleanor's eyes her father Elliott was
a heroic figure he was handsome rugged
and manly which is not surprising
considering that he was the brother of
the future presidents and quintessential
man of action Theodore Roosevelt Eliot
was a hunter who would travel around the
world collecting trophies and stories
with which she would entrace his little
girl Elliot and Eleanor who he called
Nellie shares a very special bond she
later recalled with my father I was
perfectly happy he was the center of my
world and all around him loved him but
Elias has a not-so-secret vice he was a
raging alcoholic when he wasn't playing
polo or hunting elephants in Africa he
could be found at the Meadow Brook
country club drinking away the day he
was an anxious moody young man who was
never able to relax often he would go on
extended drinking binges to eventually
stagger through the door in an
apoplectic state by her own assessment
Eleanor was a plain looking child
without beauty and she was also
painfully shy she was raised in the
midst of privilege and wealth family
they lived in a townhouse in Manhattan
that was staffed full of servants the
image Eleanor was
for by a French nurse as a result she
learned to speak French before she could
even speak English when he broke his
ankle in 1893 alia began adding laudanum
and morphine to his diet of mood
altering substances Anna tried to help
him break his substance dependence but
it was all to no avail then after the
birth of their second child Eliot jr. in
1889 there was a kind of family
intervention spearheaded by his older
brother Teddy he convinced Eliot
to leave the family and head south in
order to clean himself up Eliot returns
after a few months better but not cured
he would wander the house at night
desperately looking for a drink in order
to help him deal with his chronic
depression at a wits ends and a persuade
him to take the family on a tour of
European health resorts for six-year-old
Eleanor the trip was absolutely magical
having been separated from him for
months she was now able to spend every
minute with her beloved papa she went
out of her way to please him dreading
nothing more than displeasing him for
his part Eliot loved everything about
his daughter apart from one thing she
later recalled I was not only timid I
was afraid of everything of mice of the
dark of imaginary dangers in reminiscing
about her childhood Allen recalled in
her autobiography looking back childhood
and my youth was one long battle against
fear by the time that a third child a
boy named Hall came along in 1891 Eliot
was back to his heavy drinking the
family were in Paris and Elliot's
condition had become so bad that he was
now confined to a sanatorium it was now
that big brother Theodore Roosevelt
stepped in in order to take charge he
sailed to Paris to confront his wayward
brother he ordered him to spend two
years apart from the family in order to
overcome his demons he could reunite
with his family when he had proven to
Theodore that he was a changed man on
his return to the States
Eliot settled down in a small town in
Virginia back in New York Anna was
miserable
she missed her husband desperately and
seemed to be bitter with everything and
everyone Alanna was just as miserable
she couldn't understand why her beloved
father had gone away and she missed him
terribly
Anna hired a private tutor for Alana who
would teach the girl in the upstairs
parlor of their men how
in town house when eleanor was 7 her
mother began getting severe migraine
headaches she would place to herself in
her bedroom with all of the shades drawn
for days on end Helena would spent hours
sitting by her bedside gently rubbing
her mother's forehead for the first time
in her life she felt as if she were
actually being useful to Anna
[Music]
Anna had surgery for an unknown illness
just before Eleanor
turned eight following the operation she
came down with diphtheria within days
the 29 year old mother of three she was
dead Alona was sent to live with
relatives she was soon told that her
father was on his way to see her this
ray of light it up shown the sadness of
her mother's passing
she created the fantasy that she and her
father would go off and live together in
some faraway place but that wasn't to be
Anna had stipulated in her will that the
children were to be raised by a mother
Mary Livingston Ludlow as a results and
I found herself living in a gloomy
Manhattan brownstone house in the spring
both of Ellen's brothers they contracted
scarlet fever the baby got better
service three year old Elliott Jr's
condition it developed into diphtheria
and unfortunately he died and his only
happiness came with the infrequent
visits of her father but Elliott he was
still drinking heavily and elders
grandmother put a stop to the visits in
the summer of 1894 Elliott suffered a
fall while in a drunken stupor he fell
into a coma and ultimately died Alona
she was devastated she later wrote I
continued living in my dream world as
usual from that time I knew in my mind
that my father was dead but yet I lived
with him more closely probably than when
he was alive
Eleanor and younger brother Hall they
were now orphaned and they lived with
their grandmother and her four grown
children in the Manhattan house they
were raised with the strictest
discipline her grandmother made Ellen a
dress like a little girl in dark and
gloomy clothing this invited ridicule
from the other girls in the neighborhood
at the age of 14 Eleanor was allowed to
attend her aunt's and your Christmas
party she absolutely hated it later
writing but the others all knew each
other and saw each other often they were
all so much better at winter sports I
knew of course that I was different from
all the other girls and if I had not
known they were Franken telling me so
that evening she stood dejectedly
against the wall and watched her cousin
Alice dancing with an attractive distant
cousin by the name of Franklin Delano
Roosevelt Eleanor was mortified when
after the dance was finished the 16 year
old boy approached errands asked her for
the next dance
[Music]
at the age of 15 and fulfillment of a
mother's wishes Eleanor was sent to the
Allenswood Academy a finishing school
just outside of London England she spent
three years there from 1899 to 1902 the
Academy was headed by a French woman
named Marie su vestra the goal of the
Academy was to turn out independent
thinking young women who challenged the
stereotypical role of women in society
pelennor sheep flourished in this
environment madame Silvestre only
allowed the girls to speak French which
put Eleanor at an immediate advantage
she was a fluent speaker and spent the
first evening in animated conversation
with the headmistress swarthy other
girls sat around nervously Eleanor
quickly gains that confidence and
self-assuredness that she'd been lacking
at home she immediately became a
favorite among the girls and was a bit
of a teacher's pet it was from Madame
Silvestre that she developed a
compassion for the less privileged
members of society and a desire to use
her privileged position to help others
[Music]
in 1902
Eleanor returned to New York the 17 year
old was ready to be presented to high
society this occurred by way of a
special coming-out party it was a night
that she did not remember fondly writing
it was simply awful
it was a beautiful party of course but I
was so unhappy because a girl who comes
out is so utterly miserable if she does
not know all the young people of course
I had been so long abroad that I'd lost
touch with all the girls I used to know
in New York I was miserable through all
that without painful experience out of
the way Helena started to get involved
in settlement work in New York
encouraged by her uncle Fyodor she again
to work to improve the living conditions
of New York's poor people how I
consisted of exposing the terrible
working conditions of the many
sweatshops that employed children and
women for dangerous work for a pittance
of pay
during the summer of 1902 eleanor was on
a train to visit her grandmother when
she happened to meet up with a boy hood
asked her to dance at the Christmas
party all of those years ago Franklin
Roosevelt was the fifth cousin of Ellen
as father but the parents struck up a
conversation with Elinor soon
discovering that this young man had a
lot of depth Tim he was interested in
the social concerns that she was
passionate about and was fascinated when
she describes the working conditions
that she had witnessed Eleanor and
Franklin maintained a correspondence
which eventually developed into a
romance they were engaged on November
the 22nd 1903 Franklin's mother Sarah
and Delano was opposed to the Union and
tried to dissuade her son but to no
avail
wedding bands were made with adjustments
to fit with uncle Theodore who was now
the President of the United States
Teddy proudly gave away the bride on
March the 17th 1905 because of the
president's attendance the wedding was
the talk of the town after the nuptials
were completed the couple went on a
three-month climbing tour of Europe
returning to New York they moved into a
New York townhouse that was paid for by
Franklin's mother who was still not
having with her son's choice of wife the
home was connected to Sarah's residence
by a sliding door and she ran the roost
in both dwellings much to Eleanor's
chagrin
over a period of 10 years starting in
1906 the Roosevelts they would have six
children still Ilana liked neither the
act of procreation nor the fact of being
a mother she later wrote that it did not
come naturally to me to understand
little children or to enjoy them while
eleanor spends her time raising children
husbands progressively climbs the
political ladder by 1918 he had already
served as a New York State Senator and
was the assistant secretary of the Navy
he had also been busy himself with more
amorous affairs
Elano was unpacking a husband suitcase
one day when she stumbled across the
stack of love letters that were
addressed to him they were from social
secretary a girl named Lucy Mercer it
turns out that Franklin had become
disillusioned with his domestic life and
was planning to divorce Alan urns take
up with Lucy
when his mother threatened to disinherit
him if he caused such a scandal he
changed his mind from that point on
Helena consigned herself to a loveless
marriage of political convenience she
threw herself into her social work which
was the only thing that really gave her
pleasure during the war years Eleanor
worked as a volunteer for the Navy
Relief Society in the American Red Cross
then in 1919 she became a translator for
the International Congress of working
women in 1920 Franklin who was known to
the public as FDR ran on the Democratic
ticket for Vice President of the United
States the Republicans though they won
the White House that year and Roosevelt
returned to his law practice in New York
in August 1921 the Roosevelt vacations
at their resort home in New Brunswick
Canada at that time there was an
international polio epidemic around the
world
Franklin contracted the illness and he
became paralyzed from the waist down
Eleanor threw herself into the role of
nurse and comforter she convinced her
husband to remain in politics despite
his mother surgeons that he retire and
live out his life as a country gentleman
throughout the early 1920s Franklin
underwent a torturous routine of
physical therapy eleanor was at his side
the entire time yet she also found time
to extend her own social activity
joining the women's trade union League
and organization that worked to achieve
their treatments and better salaries for
working women she also became the board
member of the women's City Club of New
York she developed her public speaking
ability and became an in-demand speaker
around New York during this period Ilona
also founded a business called val-kill
industries this was a Furniture Factory
which employed women to build and
decorate colonial star furniture as if
all of this wasn't enough to keep the
mother of six busy she was also the
co-owner and a teacher at the Todhunter
school for girls in New York City by
1928 FDR was ready to re-enter the
political arena again
Eleanor she was right by his side he ran
form dens became the Governor of New
York Eleanor she was now the first lady
of New York she was very active in the
role becoming according to a husband his
eyes and legs
even though FDR's inability to walk was
hidden from the public Helena did all of
the traveling for him in the process she
delivered speeches on his behalf the
position gave her an ideal opportunity
to fulfill her social agenda
in 1932 Neff d'art was propelled to the
White House on March the 4th 1933
Eleanor was sworn in as the First Lady
of the United States it was a role that
she had been dreading she had known
every First Lady of the 20th century up
until that time and was certainly not
keen to spend her days hosting luncheons
and planning state occasions from the
very outset eleanor was determined to
revolutionize the role of the first lady
she saw the role as the ultimate
position of influence by which she could
bring real change for the
underprivileged she continued and even
extended her social activities two days
after becoming first lady Allen set the
stage by holding the first ever press
conference held by a first lady she
would go on to hold another 347 of these
conferences during her husband's
presidency she also began writing a
daily newspaper column which became a
major platform for her to espouse her
views the column was widely syndicated
all across the country the most
important seer to take in Eleanor's
message was of course her husband she
brought him stories from all over the
country of the hardship and injustice
that people were facing this no doubt
had an influence on many of FDR's
policies during the New Deal that was in
place during the Depression years
[Music]
Elinor was responsible for bringing a
civil rights agenda to the White House
in 1939 the Daughters of the American
Revolution denied black singer Marian
Anderson the right to perform at
Carnegie Hall
Elinor immediately came to Anderson's
age and was instrumental in organizing
an open-air concert at the Lincoln
Memorial that was attended by 75,000
people during World War two
and learn his role it became
international in its scope she undertook
a dangerous trip to the South Pacific
theater of war in order to bolster the
troops the following year she undertook
a goodwill tour of Latin America she
wanted to do more including going to
Europe to work for the International Red
Cross but was dissuaded by presidential
advisors Eleanor she actively lobbied to
allow European refugee children to
immigrate to the United States along
with Jews and other groups who under
Nazi oppression she was partially
successful helping 83 Jewish refugees
into the country on one occasion at the
end of the war however she stated that
her greatest regret that she was unable
to convince the President to accept more
escapees from Nazi tyranny
with the walk drawing to a successful
conclusion Franklin Roosevelt he
suddenly died on April the 12th 1945 he
suffered a cerebral hemorrhage while
visiting Warm Springs Georgia Ellen has
grief it was complicated by the
information that her husband's longtime
mistress Lucy Mercer Rutherford had been
with him when he died Franklin had never
given up on Lucy just by giving that
impression to Eleanor letters and phone
calls continued throughout the 1920s
during the White House years he would
invite Lucy to visit when Eleanor was
away FDR recruited his daughter Anna to
help arrange these clandestine visits
and I knew the depth of the relationship
and she was a willing accomplice this is
something that deeply hurt Eleanor when
she learned about it after her husband's
death there has been a lot of
speculation regarding Eleanor's
extramarital activity the focus of the
attention is on a political reporter by
the name of Lorena Hickok Lorena and
Eleanor
they became constant companions there
are many surviving letters between the
couple that could be interpreted as
being romantic in nature it is also
common knowledge that Hickok was a
lesbian the relationship may or may not
have been physical but there is little
doubt that the two women certainly loved
each other finding herself suddenly out
of the white house Helena retired to the
family estate at Hyde Park she could see
no future as a public person and made up
her mind to simply fade into the sunset
the new president Harry Truman he had
other ideas
he called Eleanor the first lady of the
world and a vedera position as a
delegate to that newly created United
Nations her sense of duty it kicked in
and she accepted the role in 1946 she
became the first chairperson of the
United Nations Commission on Human
Rights she was instrumental in drafting
the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights working with the UN until 1953
the final decade of Eleanor's life was
spent giving speeches and making
occasional appearances throughout the
1950s she gave an average of a hundred
and fifty speeches a year many of them
on behalf of the United Nations
she received a slew of awards and
honorary titles and was the first
recipient of the annual Franklin Delano
Roosevelt Brotherhood award in 1946
in 1960 eleanor was diagnosed with
aplastic anemia following accidents in
which she was hit by a car in New York
she was treated with steroids but this
made things worse a dormant case of
tuberculosis in a Byrne marrow is
activated and it was this that led to
the cardiac arrest the kilter on
November the 7th 1962 she was 78 years
old
the following day President Kennedy
ordered that every US flag around the
world must be lowered to half-mast as a
tribute to the first lady of the world
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and do not forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
just like this several times a week so
subscribe to make sure you get those
also why not check out my other channel
called top tens you'll find a link to
that in the description below and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]